sin embargo, al decirle que tiene que guardarlo
que con la condición de que no seas Darsena
estado en espera de nidos que establecerías
transporte
ambiente
[Música]
Florida De Santis Paradis crea un e
en el país enviando emigrantes a él
Sudates a lo grande como Nueva York y
Washington, que normalmente son un
refluvio para en migrante si te refieres
ayudarles a
selección de mis terminales
favorisseria no y llevó a
conservatorio
el tema
del expresidente Trump describió
Por ejemplo
en las fugas no se jugaba ladrone
scriminales violadores y Emaús Senti
esas cosas en tragamonedas americanas
en lugar de ser una continuación de la
tema trompista que el emigrante en un
enemigo y quien se quedo con esa charlotte si no
no la dejen entrar al pais e
los demócratas son
disfavorsen eporesso tiene esa serie
sigamas de exposición despejadas
sedere y en el campo
nada presiona porque la casa blanca
porque el sistema no lo necesita
formato para claramente no el congreso
estuvo expuesta al pecho y especialmente
nuestra razón republicana
Siempre estamos cuando tiene su Crisis
Aygo usando para para criticar a un
biden a los demócratas para la selección
tanto de medio termino como del 6 de noviembre y word
Próximas elecciones presidenciales en
últimos 24